despite the weather this Black Friday
millions of shoppers are making an
early-morning beeline to stores across
the country a new analysis shows get
this more than 165 million Americans are
expected to look for bargains during the
five-day stretch that runs from
Thanksgiving Day through Cyber Monday
big retailers are feeling more pressure
than ever from record-breaking
online rivals Niki batiste is at a Best
Buy store in Paramus New Jersey Nikki
what do shoppers seem to have their eyes
on this early well drink a good morning
as hard as it is to resist online
shopping there people out in their cars
it's freezing outside waiting to come in
here and a lot of them have their eyes
on TVs some of them are up to 50% off
here at Best Buy the doors will finally
open at 8:00 a.m. some Black Friday
shoppers say it really just comes down
to good old holiday tradition
there's no need to wait until Friday for
these bargain hunters as doors opened on
Thanksgiving Day shoppers had just one
thing in mind save big I bought TV I
bought air fryer I bought iPad Mini so
I'm like really had really happy to get
this good deal and if this year's crowds
at Macy's in New York City are any
measure a finished sixth example I
formed the line so every civilized we
can all get what we want
Black Friday deals are no joke two savvy
shoppers first I cook all night long and
then I shop until I drop Toys R Us made
a comeback this year as a reopened its
first store in New Jersey
Black Friday has been synonymous with
scenes like these but this year
what does Black Friday 2019 look like
it's gonna be a little bit less frantic
than last year Wall Street Journal
retail reporter Sarah Nass hour says
more people are opting to shop from
their cozy couch for the first time the
majority of US consumers fifty-four
percent say they will do most of their
holiday shopping online only about 36
percent plan to shop on Black Friday
this year down from 51 percent in 2016
what's your advice to shoppers debating
whether or not to get off the couch and
go out and shop on Black Friday make a
list
stick to your list did you see something
good you've been tracking the price now
and then it's a good time to pull the
trigger and buy it another hot ticket
item here is laptop some of them selling
for just about $200 the big question
this year is who's going to win the
sales war Black Friday or Cyber Monday
Black Friday is expected to bring in 7
billion in sales but analysts at Adobe
analytics say cyber monday could bring
in more than nine and a half billion and
David that's up 20 percent from last
year
$200 computers bring a couple back
where's the crowd Nicki are they outside
until 8 a.m. there
their cars outside it's breezy and look
who got in